but uh the first story check us out from
the ap disputing
trump barr says no widespread election
fraud but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna waste words with their
opinion i'll give you his act quote
barr told the ap that u.s attorneys and
fbi agents have been working to follow
up specific complaints and information
they've received but quote
to date we have not seen fraud on a
scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election the comments
which drew immediate criticism from
trump attorneys
were especially notable coming from barr
who has been one of the president's most
ardent allies
before the election he had repeatedly
raised the notion that mail-in voting
could be especially vulnerable to fraud
during the coronavirus pandemic
as americans feared going to polls and
instead chose to vote by mail
more to trump's liking barr revealed in
an ap interview that in october he had
appointed u.s attorney john durham as a
special counsel
giving the prosecutor the authority to
continue to investigate the origins of
the trump russia probe
after biden takes over and making it
difficult to fire him
biden hasn't said what he might do with
the investigation
but but his transition team didn't
comment on tuesday so let's
let's just start talking about what's
going on with you know bill barr
statements
i don't know if you've been following a
lot of the voter fraud stuff ben i have
absolutely well first let me just then
just what are your thoughts on the whole
thing
well i think that the big problem here
is that we have a system that really is
not designed
to be able to quickly prove
voter fraud on the scale that may have
happened in this case
the doj is really built to make cases to
investigate situations
to bring a case eventually to court that
can take years
and i think that the real problem is
that we're discovering that in a
situation like this one where they
rushed
all of these changes many of which i
think may turn out in the uh
eventually to be considered
unconstitutional on the state level as
uh your guest sean parnell was bringing
up oh yeah the other day
he's the plaintiff yes exactly um which
i think is a very serious question
the real problem is what if the fraud is
hiding in plain sight
and i know that during the russia hoax
you would always hear that from you know
adam schiff and people like that oh you
know the collusion's higher
it's hiding in plain sight you know it's
right there it's right in front of you
what if instead the actual fraud is
something as basic as
mark zuckerberg spending hundreds of
millions of dollars to have
voter boxes put all over the united
states in ways that
may turn out to be targeted to specific
areas in you know things that could turn
out to be in-kind contributions to
democrats as opposed to non-profits or
uh wisconsin they were doing democracy
in the park events
yes bringing people out telling them to
vote telling them who to vote for things
like that
and it's it's a situation where i mean
you know our own reporter
john davidson who uh you know does a lot
of this stuff on the ground for us has
been detailing
the situations in uh native american
communities
where you literally had illegal raffles
and things like that going on to
incentivize people to vote
which is stuff that you know it's just
basic law like you can't pay someone to
vote or not vote you know it's
and and to me all of that adds up
to a situation where there really is
rampant
you know fraud weirdness lots of
questions
but i don't think we have the capacity
in the doj
to turn something around that quickly in
a way that would satisfy americans
and that to me is is that's a big
unanswered question
that's it i completely agree and i
mentioned this one of the biggest
problems we have is what we get two
weeks
to do this full-scale nationwide
investigation of 150 million votes
that's impossible but we have more and
more evidence stacking up
now to clarify what barr has said
they're saying he's saying no evidence
of widespread fraud in fact i've titled
this stream no evidence of widespread
fraud what he said was to date
we have not seen fraud on a scale that
could have affected a different outcome
in the election
we can break that down it could mean
several things he could be saying as of
right now
we have seen fraud we haven't seen
enough does it mean he's done
investigating no it doesn't
but of course the headline from every
mainstream is going to be no evidence of
widespread fraud
i i default in that direction as well
but it's really hard to like
cram a title in you know on youtube so i
have to do i do what i can i'm basing
off the article
it could theoretically mean we've seen
fraud
we haven't seen enough yet he did say to
date right
i think i'm thinking about james clapper
just keep thinking about james clapper
testifying to congress that
they did not yeah we did not wittingly
spy on the american people when they did
wittingly spy
and under oath perjury to congress
and no no repercussions no none no so it
makes me think they're all
capable of lying well of course they are
i mean john brennan is someone who
didn't just spy on the american people
he spied on congress
but but no just just full of it i don't
know let's
bill barr is the attorney general yeah
and then uh
clapper was he was a former cia foreign
brennan and cia yes okay there we go
just want to make sure but continue
but so the thing that i think we need to
keep in mind here is
effectively what bar is saying is he
can't answer that question
he doesn't actually have the capability
to find that in such a short amount of
time
at the same time i think that he is
really engaged here
in a bit of setting expectations which
is
we all know that this mail-in balloting
thing was something that
a lot of folks mostly on the left have
been pushing for for a long time
it's it's not going away they're going
to keep it in the in the midterms
they're going to try to keep it for the
next presidential and to me
at a certain point the attitude of
people who
want to see the trump agenda furthered
who supported him this time around who
are furious at this result
has to be we can't let this happen again
because otherwise it will and it's in
the incentives of a lot of these
politicians to make sure that it does
so that they don't have some reversal of
fortune in the midterms as they all
expect they will so this is
the most important thing coming out of
all of this if maybe
trump doesn't win right i know the trump
supporters are saying we're going to win
we got to fight
oh you know look i i've been saying over
and over again that in my opinion it was
always extremely likely
once they called it for biden it's going
to be biden but trump
should keep fighting no matter what
because we have seen historic anomalies
this like the georgio they found all
these votes
and there's a possibility trump could
figure out a legal path to victory
through legal challenges
and through the electoral college but
outside of all of that let's say the
worst case scenario
for the trump supporters is that it's
done trump loses joe biden's president
this fight that trump has led will push
us towards more secure voting
at the very least and it could also mean
no mail in voting
the fight coming from people like mike
kelly i think mike kelly's name and sean
parnell
could result in more secure elections no
universal mail in voting
and i hear from all these leftists and
democrats saying but universal mail in
voting is so easy and so popular even
republicans love it and i'm like yes it
is easy i completely agree
and easy doesn't mean secure in fact the
more you
remove security the easier things get
but then
the more likely you're going to see
fraud or impropriety and we want secure
elections
we want to be able to audit them
properly we want observers i think
at the very end of this the worst case
scenario is
we're gonna have grounds based on the
things they find or have already found
to say no to a lot of this no excuse
mail-in voting and demand more secure
elections and things like voter id for
instance
i think that that is that's a hopeful
image and i hope that
that is something that comes forward
because i'm concerned about the trust
level that's going to exist among
the american people we've seen the total
degradation of faith
in every institution of american life
basically
people trust the military and small
business and that's it if you look at
all the polls
and so at the end of the day this is
going to be one more aspect that people
have a lack of trust for given the
closeness of proximity of the electoral
college and
the fact that we're probably going to
see something like this play out again
in two years or four years and it
without major changes
you know what's really crazy about the
whole thing though is that if
so the pennsylvania state legislature
said we don't have enough time to pass a
joint resolution calling the election
in dispute they could have that's freaky
to me that we could have a
whole federal election let's look at
this way let's say
2024 i can't imagine joe biden running
for reelection
i just i don't see it so maybe it's you
know kamala harris now she's going to
run for president
you know going from vice president to
president or whatever i'm saying
hypothetically she's running against i
don't know who
do you think would run in 2024 for the
republican a lot of people will but
let's
let's just say for the argument just
because he's known and a known commodity
west ted cruz
let's just say ted cruz because he came
in second effectively last time all
right so we got ted cruz
kamala harris comes down the electoral
college ted cruz is up
he's projected to win and then a swing
state with
a democratic legislature says we're
going to appoint
our electors we're going to dispute it
pulling his you know his votes away or
something like that
that could happen now and that to me is
kind of nuts that trump needed three
states
he needs three states it can still
happen to effectively challenge
the uh the result of the election it it
might actually happen
i mean we just had this hearing in what
was it michigan today where
it was this is the first time i think of
these hearings they've done it was
actually in a state house it was
actually in an official building
they were doing these hotels before
right so they had the first
evidentiary hearing with the republican
state legislature
in uh uh pennsylvania i think it was
right in gettysburg right
and when i questioned why they're doing
in a hotel a ton of people were saying
oh it's gettysburg it's the second you
know gettysburg address or whatever and
i'm just like i don't know i kind of
feel like they're just
you know placating people you're like oh
yeah we're gonna do a hearing it's gonna
be a hotel
when they did it in arizona to hyatt i
said that makes no sense okay there's no
there's no the hyatt speech there's no
you know the phoenix address or whatever
but now they're in michigan they
actually had a legit hearing and there
was some
i mean it's the stories that are coming
out of this stuff are insane
people saying they're being harassed
chased out they're not allowed to
observe at all in all these places
weird stories about trucks pulling up in
the middle of the night you know pulling
out boxes of ballots and things like
that claiming
we're not counting but then they add
vote counts later on clearly something
weird's going on
and that's that's not even the the half
of it and and what i really want to say
to
everybody who you know has been arguing
with their friends
about you know fraud in this election
where people might be citing cnn to them
saying oh there is no fraud
there's fraud in every american election
it always happens and it's typically
on a low level and very pedestrian
in nature it's literally a box that
appears or disappears
you know it's something that it doesn't
take a convoluted machine
to make it work i mean the machine that
ran in
new orleans all the way up until katrina
was totally like that it was organic
everyone knew what they had to do it
didn't require any kind of coordination
or meetings
katrina smashes that whole population it
spreads out and suddenly republicans
start winning elections
and that's something that i think you
know speaks to the organic
built into the society nature of these
things of a place like philly
um and again i still think this is a
situation where
this was effectively lost for donald
trump
when republican lawyers didn't get their
act together
ahead of time months ago and start
fighting and disputing these things more
effectively
within these different systems they were
getting shut down by the courts but they
needed to put more effort into it
because i think that the the moment that
those rules were locked in
they were facing a circumstance where if
he lost the state it would be almost
impossible to prove enough
right you know what i've been saying i
said trump got oceans 11.
that the real heist happened months ago
in october
uh of 2019 in in pennsylvania the
republicans passed acts 77
which other republicans are now suing
calling it unconstitutional
why did they pass no excuse mail-in
voting before covet happened
they knew mail-in voting was always
their path
to essentially cheating the election and
and the reason i say cheating is that
changing the rules the 11th hour to
benefit one side because you know it's
what you need
is it's cheating yeah so it what it
they they say covet is the excuse when i
when i talk about people say well people
were scared of code they needed an
option no no
because they were already passing these
bills you know in other places and then
when you talk about the the anomalies
for instance
they say and i'm kind of sidetracking
here they say the anomalies are
easily explained because the republic
you know the republicans stop them from
counting ballots until election night
which was not true for some states
there's just those weird anomalous
spikes but anyway going back to the
oceans getting oceans 11 they pass all
of these rule changes
where i'd been making video after video
saying
this is the how they're going to how
they're going to how they're going to
cheat
republicans are going to show up on
election day like they normally do
and they're going to follow the rules
and democrats have every opportunity now
to hold democracy in the park events to
do you know what raffles you were
mentioning illegal raffles
there's accusations of of ballot
harvesting now we've got minnesota
and in what was the other one texas
where where the veritas
yeah i believe i haven't been able to
follow veritas has been putting out so
many things that i'm a little behind my
veritas consumption i have to admit but
congrats to them
yeah yeah so that we we have you know
these videos showing people are doing
about harvesting we had on jeremy from
the quartering
and he said that at his house like
democrats showed up and we're like
have you voted do you have your absentee
ballots and they received them but he
never requested one
so there's a lot of weird things there
but there's i think i think one of the
simple things is maybe this is fraud
maybe they were requesting bouts for
people and then showing up and telling
them to vote
or maybe they gave themselves a month
plus
to go to go around telling people did
you vote yet did you vote
why don't you vote did you vote we saw
in one of the videos from veritas a
woman saying she was like hey come out
and have free drinks with me
did you vote and so they're like okay
fine they fill it out there you go here
take my vote now give me the beer
yeah that kind of ballot harvesting that
was the trick because guess what that's
a real vote yes
now there is freaky stuff like matt
brainard for the voter integrity project
says
here's 20 plus thousand people who
change their addresses and then voted
twice
that's like okay we kind of got evidence
of widespread fraud going on
maybe maybe it wasn't enough to change
the results or maybe you know bill barr
looked at it
and then said uh this is not legit
i don't know yeah i think that that's
impossible to know and i think we'll be
pouring over this for a long time but i
do think that
we're now in territory where one side
definitely thinks that they got jobbed
and the other side definitely thinks
that they won but they have the sour
taste in their mouth because of how
unwilling the other side is to accept it
and because of the performance of
republicans generally
uh so that sets up a a very
strife-filled political scenario
where joe biden is absolutely not going
to unify anybody
no it's going to be joe biden is the
worst possible thing to have happened to
this country
especially right now but i'll tell you
first and foremost i'm sorry if if i
can't believe joe biden won fair and
square you know why
trump wins the republicans win down
ballot they reclaim
many house seats they lost none they
gained many they didn't take the
majority
they defended the senate they won every
state a state house
or state race so it looked like trump
was on the ticket
then joe biden who doesn't didn't
campaign i mean he literally campaigned
but you know what i mean like
come on he's in the basement at the time
he's calling lids every day
he was not having big events or any
rallies somehow beat barack obama's 2008
ground shattering you know 69 million
votes
joe biden didn't campaign and beat trump
the argument i hear is
people hate trump that much that they
voted against him i don't i don't think
so
biden also i mean they also outspent him
uh and out manipulated uh him in ways
that we can't
leave out of this the in-kind donation
from big tech
oh absolutely absolutely i mean i don't
even know how you could estimate it
um the amount of money that they spent
obviously they spent almost twice as
much money just from the campaign
organizations etc yeah and so i think
this is a situation where
money did talk this time around and also
that the
the warping influence that we've had on
narrative
from an entire corporate democrat media
establishment
designed to take down trump focused on
you know telling the entire country that
he's this racist horrible
person who has to be destroyed for the
sake of humanity
for year upon year upon year and they
end up with a situation where you know
he wins
more votes than barack obama actually
did and you know
wins uh you know more votes than any you
know any republican and it's it's this
i know i mean it's kind of amazing i
know too many democrats who switched
parties
it you know coming out of chicago there
are people i've known my whole life who
have always been democrat kind of
passively
now hardcore trump supporters and so i
see things like that
that's obviously anecdotal doesn't mean
you know that's that's my personal
friend and family bubble but i i look at
uh
the new york times reporting i look at
moody's analytics all of these things in
indicating a trump victory nothing
indicating a trump defeat albeit when
covid hit
it shifted a lot of the economic
forecasts thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you